[Music]
everybody going in wake up early in the
morning press play and let's get it in
cause we rocking with the fighter
[Music]
[Applause]
shows yeah yeah man that's what's up hey
a few [ __ ] hit me up like that like
you ain't never hit me up for that show
i'm like it's it's an apartment yeah i'm
not like that i don't know
why you missed it i did tell me about it
bro it was no furniture yeah like women
on the floor
had a skype i was like just a bunch of
them
[Applause]
in the bathroom for real damn
they're missing out man snack snacks
holy headliners
stoppers are headliners only now
[Music]
that'd be funny if you did take all the
money though [ __ ] it's your apartment
man yeah [ __ ] it yeah
let's introduce the guests man tomorrow
neighbors
[Applause]
thanks coming through man thanks for
having me man fitness man in comedy
y'all [ __ ] be having so much fun on
this show
i'm like what the [ __ ] do y'all be doing
in there like
what are you just good times
positive attitude just hanging bro yeah
i was uh you
how long were you in texas [ __ ] like two
months right
no no no no no like a week oh not two oh
really
um yeah it was it was dealt because i
reached out to you because you're on
rogan and i've always liked you i'm not
just saying
i've always liked because you were
always so nice to me at the comedy store
sometimes you can fight yeah
[Applause]
man and then you crush on rogan i was
like [ __ ] i can't believe we've never
had you on the show man yeah man
yeah man i can't believe yeah i can't
believe y'all [ __ ] never had it
like that's on me man it's kinda on them
but that's on me
a little bit you need to sean his
apartment well hold on i can't throw him
in there he didn't
like me shout out to the apartment show
that is oh yeah
yeah man it was live on that apartment
show man how many man
live [ __ ] [ __ ] like we was known for
like months
like i've done at least five of them
right
yeah and the neighbors were cool with it
we got the cops caught on us
one time because it was that lit damn
see look at it
he was about to turn a professional
boxer yeah yeah yeah
yeah i tell you what i've been seeing
him longer but
i've been cooler with mali
he's all we have known each other but i
like marion
i used to open up for hannibal huh uh no
i just hope for hannibal one time
oh okay yeah that'd be opening for him
though huh that you opened for him
yeah just i think it was just one you
weren't like on tour with him no i
didn't go on twitter oh i could have
swore
i was like oh that's that [ __ ] would be
opening up for hannibal no
oh you might that's how i knew you asked
wait how so how did you save him from uh
boxing okay so jamar i've been training
for like
we met like three years and like oh
before that though
even before that maybe like three years
even before i even uh met you though
so training for like six years he taught
himself on youtube
okay he taught us that there you go
there you go
he i take him to wildcard yeah i was
like hey bro they hit in wildcard right
so he's like
why did you take in a while because i
thought he can box look [ __ ]
no but here's the thing he would get in
the ring he was getting ready now he had
a wild card
yes yeah but sometimes that's that's a
dangerous man
like like going to wild card is like
doing your first set at the main room in
the comedy store
you know and be like yo you like comedy
here's the main room you're like what
the [ __ ] but he's even boxing for three
years
i'ma trust him not if he was like hey
dog i'm watching shitload of youtube no
after the fact no i'm like we're gonna
take you to boxing
go away go ahead so i i went to uh i
would go to fortune boxing gym that was
yeah ice cream
yeah and uh stop like like i think they
like shut down for a second i was like i
gotta get it in
and i was like [ __ ] it man i'm gonna
just go to wildcard i don't know about
wild card like that i'm
trying to go to a gym [ __ ] then i come
in here the guy i had an all weight vest
i had on like weights on my feet
what can you do what and he
listen he was driving yeah yeah he gets
down
no he's in shape he's in shape so he
fooled me something oh he must train all
the time solid bro you want some work
and i'm like yeah yeah
but it was someone who was green but not
green so he went in there and he
survived
and then he said you ladies gotta get
that kind of little dicey as you would
say i was like oh jamar now get out get
out get out
then i get a text like two weeks later
he was like bro if i train hard for the
next like
let's say a couple of months and i go to
mexico and build my record up you think
i got
oh no wait this is a serious question
serious question
because because at a point i would train
so much i really just trying to just be
in shape yeah you love you know what i'm
saying
and then so uh so i used to do the so i
did the boxing workout because i don't
want to be like buff i just want to be
like lean shredded
and then so uh i just slowly like just
start watching people around the gym and
[ __ ] like that and i
look at people and i'll be like oh [ __ ]
that [ __ ]
he's athletic yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
you hit the bags
yeah so then you talked him out of it i
talked him out i had to because i like
jamar
also but it's not like you have no other
skills yeah like if your thing was like
man
i need to do something here like you're
yeah you know what i'm saying
i got to protect this thing i got better
over time though
right and then i uh and then i thought
that i was good
and then i jumped in there with this
[ __ ] oh yeah
i didn't know that he's part everybody
like like he's part floyd mayweather
yeah
i don't know who i was in there with
it's like chris tucker he's like which
one are y'all
[Laughter]
yeah and then you asked me to spar yeah
five minutes we've been talking he tried
beating you up didn't invite you to his
show no you longer no longer
here's the thing he uh like so i'll get
i don't give a [ __ ] i'll jump and i'll
spar with anybody i don't go [ __ ]
and then so uh chappelle was coming and
stuff and i was like i was like chapelle
man jump on in there yeah i was like i
was like [ __ ] i'm still learning my
role
i literally said that i was like let's
just try to get it
you want
because i saw you spar like those other
dudes who've been fighting yeah
and like if you if you're down to get in
the ring with them what what what did
rogan tell you about fighting
yeah what are you saying he's usually
pretty harsh too
okay you gotta look at from from our
perspective like i actually did it now
i'm
on the outside looking in rogan sees a
ton of it
so we see how the movie ends for a lot
of these guys who do this
um okay i i was gonna do the golden
glove remember i was yeah remember i was
gonna do the gold on the right i was
trying to be friends right before corona
that makes sense yeah i was at the like
oh [ __ ] let me do it because i heard
that uh martin did it and i heard that
uh
eddie murphy had did you have the silver
gloves or some [ __ ] and i was like
did the uh uh the golden globes yeah i
was like well
yeah i was like that's right there's
gold
uh there ain't no brown competition
silver
[ __ ] and i said dreamcast i got it all
right
i was at the like all right well it's
only right there and i was like well
then i have to do this yeah you know
like
you feel so i [ __ ] uh this [ __ ] was
training me every now and then and [ __ ]
he was like every now and then
he's going to stand up he was like have
you ever even cut weight man
i was like wait he was like yeah you got
to be a certain size then i was [ __ ] i
lost like 12 pounds in like
in like two weeks or something yeah yeah
and i walked up to rogan uh
in the um in the parking lot and i was
like rogan man i said uh i said joe i
said uh
i'm gonna i'm gonna go out for the
golden gloves and he was like wait a
minute
he was like have you ever even fought
before
i've been sparring here and there he was
like have you ever performed in front of
like a big
crowd do you get nervous and i was like
i do this joe i do stand up yeah
i'm about to go do a spot in the main
room with my shirt off
i don't give a [ __ ] i'm cool with it
yeah and then he was like all right man
just be careful
no i i would support you in golden
gloves
hey now you're like the hair girl well i
would still
i would still have you could do golden
gloves like all right maybe it'd be like
a fun journey to document like that'd be
cool
wait so what was it but you're trying to
go to tijuana and fight these mexican
guys
but again [ __ ] was that mal malek did
you saw he was he was so serious i get
obsessive like if
i i get obsessive and i like i just be
wanting to be like real great at
something if i'm trying it and [ __ ] now
something like they gotta go to mexico
and knock all them [ __ ] out yeah
mexicans know what you want yeah oh
[ __ ] i just wait so what is
the golden glove the golden gloves is a
tournament like before the trials you
know heard of the olympic trials
if you win a certain amount of golden
globes then you qualify
for a little bit and then every state
has this golden glove so there's a
california golden gloves there's
colorado colorado florida
there's new york which probably new york
is probably the best golden gloves
california is big in new york it's good
your boy won the denver golden globes
yeah okay
let's go i won uh houston and louisiana
okay yeah
and so you were trying to go to the
olympics
no you don't you don't have oh you never
know [ __ ]
you never know
man i like how brittany was about to get
up
[Applause]
his last words
what's the worst that could happen i
swear to god i
um yeah but that but then corona hit so
i didn't [ __ ] do that [ __ ] but what i
could do
next year now what i did do was i uh i
took a i took a fight in this um
in this comedian boxing
what poor soul was that [ __ ]
i was like this comic hit me up this
comic hit me up he was
like hey man i heard you box and i was
at the like yeah yeah i did
a little he was like well we're having a
boxing tournament for comics he was like
you want to jump in
and i was at the like all right because
i didn't do the golden globe i was like
i'd do this [ __ ] and i was like who you
got for me
he uh [ __ ] kept turning me down it was
like no
of course all i see is that [ __ ] wear
boxing shoes
doing sets and everything that's
facts
this big so they showed me this fat
[ __ ] right here right and
i saw this [ __ ] and he was just fat and
out of shape and i was like
i'll get around to it yeah right i just
totally like wrote the [ __ ] off or
whatever
and uh where's this at this is uh in
goosebumps
it was boxing gym and gooseman and then
so at the weigh-in at the weight i was
going to take it easy
i didn't full on weigh-ins like i was
gonna take it easy on them right
um and then like we was at the weigh-in
i was like smiling and [ __ ] and doing
this
and then he posted on his instagram like
when i was smiling he was like it's all
fun and games and somebody get hit in
the mouth
and i and i took that and i took that
personally michael he talking [ __ ]
i really took that personally he could
have been talking about me but i was
like you gonna hurt me [ __ ]
so i was like let them know dog i was
hating with my sister you beat the [ __ ]
i got real evil i was like i was hanging
on my sister i wasn't like all right so
how you want me to do this [ __ ] yeah
and i said do i kill him or do i just
i'll box him or what you went to hood on
yeah yeah [ __ ] and i was where's the
video
he was not he was not ready yeah i
played he was not ready i was like i'ma
just kill this [ __ ]
right so i uh and then so that [ __ ]
happened and um
it was like very [ __ ] you know how did
you feel after it the second one
i was like i gotta get better oh yeah
you wanted to do he texted me
why is there a guy with one glove in the
ring just in case [ __ ] pops off
i think that's uh he's like oh he's a
ref oh that's the ref with one glove
i ain't never boxing again i thought i
was gonna look like floyd
i heard that i was a [ __ ] i mean you're
a [ __ ] woman i mean
for your first one you're pretty [ __ ]
controlled
like you're not freaking out you're not
just grabbing wrestling oh malik taught
me that move
put james defensive [ __ ]
okay he he's terrified yeah yeah yeah i
told him that when i or you're gonna see
me talking to him
and i was like what'd you say you about
to die no i said i said are you scared
look you start complaining he said low
blow
and he's a comic yeah i guess
[Laughter]
you can only do this to an inexperienced
[ __ ]
yeah now his form is up because he's
like leaning yeah right
but i must say jamar when he fights up
to higher competition he looks so much
better
i've seen it though but for your first
fight look pretty [ __ ] good
look this is the widest hook ever [ __ ]
look at this [ __ ]
i said it look at this oh we went yeah
that's good that's the little streak
yeah he wasn't ready with my roast
battle shorts on [ __ ]
that's alex phillips but that dude that
dude normally box that's my coach kyle
he doesn't
oh that was that dude's first time he's
a comic i had his first time ever in the
ring
yeah first another did he do that first
and i was in there with a [ __ ] that
spar
mayweather for 12 rounds
how was your time in texas this episode
with jamar neighbors is brought to you
by blue chew blue chew
is making waves and bringing more
confidence to the bedroom bluetooth
unique online service
that delivers the same active
ingredients as viagra cialis billet
in chewable form at a fraction of the
cost as well
blue chews tablets combat all the forms
of erectile dysfunction and can help men
gain extra confidence
in the bedroom when it's time to perform
bluetooth is an online prescription
service
so no visits to the doctor office no
awkward conversations
no wait in line at the pharmacy it ships
right to your door discreet little
package it's
easy it's simple sign up at
bluetooth.com right then you consult
with other licensed medical providers
once you're approved you receive your
prescription within days
best part it's all done online blue
chews licensed medical providers will
work with you to find the right
ingredient
in strength just for you all right don't
like swung pills
cool it's blue chews so they're chewable
all right and they're made in the u.s
of a so if you could benefit from all
this
just pay five dollars shipping and go to
bluetooth.com promo code fighter receive
your first month
free and i thank blue chew for being
part of fighter and the kids
hey man insurance can be complicated
that's why the zebra was created when
you use the zebra.com
insurance finally feels like it's black
and white no more confusion no more
grayers just
honest rates from real companies the
zebra is the nation's leading insurance
comparison site
for car and home insurance they can help
you save money today it's so freaking
easy
go to the zebra.com answer a few quick
questions
to compare accurate insurance quotes for
free the zebra protects your personal
information
so there's no hidden fees no surprise
along the way you can
secure your insurance from the zebra.com
over the phone
or with their licensed insurance agents
all right
uh with state reopening and people back
on the road the zebra is committed to
making sure
you and your family are covered how much
money can you save on current home
insurance
i don't know but check it out the
zebra.com fighter that's the zebra
t-h-e-z-e-b-r-a
dot com slash fighter for insurance in
black and white
all the time how was your uh time in
texas
uh lit lit man i had a i had a [ __ ]
ball man they they really make you feel
appreciated out there like so nice out
there i was walking down the street
uh i was walking down the street and
somebody was like jamar and i was at the
like oh hey what up
and i thought i knew the [ __ ] but i
didn't know him at all he was just a fan
and i was at the like that's dope like
you don't really get that [ __ ]
out here now out here like cuz
everybody's
famous out here you know what i'm saying
so out there like it was just
they really appreciate it yeah it's like
oh jamal i love your [ __ ] and i was at
the like oh
thank you and i'm like maybe
i appreciate it yeah yeah that [ __ ]
are you thinking of moving out there i i
tell the rogan i would
you felt he felt pressured right he kept
beating
he's like real big and buff and he's
like move out here
he's like you want to you want to you
want to just bend to his will
because you don't know if that [ __ ]
gonna sock you or not for not moving out
there you say yeah thinking about it
i'm thinking about it no i mean i was
thinking i know i really was thinking
about it though because they like treat
you so [ __ ] nice but then
i'm like i don't want to maybe but you
you do stuff on like tv
too right you right yeah yeah it's tough
to do out there man
yeah and then i was doing um i had a
self tape audition
and i did it out there and i didn't like
the way i felt
doing it out there and i was like the
energy
yeah yeah yeah the creativeness is out
here i gotta feel like i'm in the
you know like i'm in the [ __ ] yep yeah
and the zeitgeist yeah yep
so so i don't know but i i mean i'm
definitely going out there for a month
i'm going to frequent for sure like i
got a month of shows lined up i think
that's the
i think that's the move yeah i think
that's what i'm going to do base out of
here and then go out there frequently
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah man cause it's
not going anywhere and then
you know there's no reason to just you
know bounce from here and then move out
there and then you're stuck out there
with a mortgage a house everything's in
that lizard
yeah and then it's cold and [ __ ] and
then you're looking back at la and
you've seen the pictures at the comedy
store and everywhere like yeah
yeah and i'm gonna wait whatever i do
but excuse me sorry i do like that it's
becoming like a another hub for us
though yeah think it's dope
because you know uh cap cities have you
performed at captain city yeah
so the they got bought out by the owner
of helium
yeah and he took the name and he opened
across
downtown now so he moved locations yeah
so you have cap cities
rogan's gonna open this spot so you got
those two now you got a lot of little
places what's the place called uh vulcan
gas company yeah
i love volcano i can't wear it like at
least six times
yeah it's dope yeah when that [ __ ] is
like sold out and
it's it's [ __ ] lit man that's what's
up huh yeah yeah yeah to me a good hub
yeah i'm excited because usually it's
like you know
la new york there's really nothing
between now you got taxes yeah yeah
and it's like a two and a half hour
flight from here too yeah like a hundred
and eight dollars
just to go get it yeah yeah [ __ ] dope
man
and all the hoes is pretty out there
yeah texas
yeah but and they just opened they so
[ __ ] like hey somebody got shot in
front of my airbnb
though out there yeah yeah you're
staying in oakland
oakland that's why yeah
oakland texas shout my airbnb
like i uh i called an uber to go to the
gym
and then i heard like four shots
and i thought it was like somebody like
placing like pallets like on top of
yeah and then i heard four more shots
and i was about to go leave
out of the airbnb and i was like um
and then i kind of like just stayed you
know a little bit now
yeah and then
and then my uber uh called me and then
he was like uh
hello um did you just get shocked
[Laughter]
i don't think so i was like nah it
wasn't me
and he was at the oh well i just saw a
guy get shot so this isn't you
just running across the street and i was
like nah man i'm in the house about to
come out to you
and he was like well somebody just got
shot in front of your airbnb um
if you still want to catch this uber
just meet me at the jack in the box up
top oh hell no on the hill and i was at
the like all right man i'm gonna just
stay in
cancel this dude daylight yeah [ __ ] was
brawl [ __ ]
like bro which is weird i mean everyone
has a gun out there but yeah
where i was standing was like really
[ __ ] sketchy though like what area
did you stand
i don't know because they got homeless
in austin yeah they sure as they'll do
they sure do yeah they [ __ ] be like by
the freeway inter pass and [ __ ] but they
got like a
they got like a they got like tents and
[ __ ] set up like like kind of like
downtown l.a a little bit here to off
off wilshire here
it's yeah yeah it was [ __ ] ruthless
in their [ __ ] it's like well
that doesn't really happen in austin
and i'm like yeah that [ __ ] happened out
here
yeah yeah that's not a first time thing
how uh what'd you do for valentine's
valentine's oh we just kicked at the
creek man you cooking nothing yeah we
cooked and [ __ ] like
what did you cook uh we uh about this
diet life though okay you didn't even
he didn't even give me a chance to say
well i know you're not because okay we
had uh
we uh did like a chick chicken tikka
masala
with rice and uh roccolini yeah bro
i went to that chicken marsala right
it's like
it's like it's like a brown like uh
gravy not on the diet though but also at
the same time we didn't do it the way
that they would normally do
with all that [ __ ] in it the butter and
all that yeah let me catch you up so
these guys have been on the diet for
like what
what's about four or five months no no
no hey six days
oh no the real one oh you didn't get fit
quicker him with me
that's that's a weird question to ask
but okay no it's not
who get fit quicker but this is what i
could this is what i can say
okay okay you've been the same size and
we've since we've been going to the gym
that's what i said he looks exactly the
same
like i'm down 10 pounds are you really
like exactly
you're doing a terrible job taking this
[ __ ] under your wing
terrible terrible and i got the jump
rope down though
you did yeah i'm gonna say brendon hey
i'm gonna say brandon [ __ ] cuz
you athletic as [ __ ] but you been the
same size
all right you know i ain't doing no more
[ __ ] talking all right
i'm day six first of all quit texting me
trying to bully me and [ __ ] talking [ __ ]
chappelle you ain't bout this [ __ ] you
ain't about this same picture of my diet
yeah
food right now yeah
if you were eating no if you're eating
right you'd respond
no i don't gotta respond you talk too
much [ __ ] what's the goal
weight where where were you two where'd
you start and where where are you now i
started
255. you started at 255. that's right
that's what i am right now
we're just going no we just started
what you're talking about wait i started
last week right it started last night
i'm six days
six days and you are six days in as well
yeah okay so you're both six days in
and i ran a [ __ ] mile he ran a mile
oh only one
win no i'm just i'm like i'm doing them
but just one month no not just
oh yeah well well i never [ __ ] ran
before
all right how much do you weigh no he
was 270. 272 six days ago how much are
y'all trying to get down to i'm trying
to get down to 240. and he's trying to
get back 220 22
and i'm trying to get to 200. how much
you weigh 173.
he's he's not you got you're not
he's not in on this he's not in on it
[ __ ]
he's like here man this is my neutral
game but
do you do anything for valentine's day
yeah what yeah yeah i went to go do a
a a hood show in san diego for um
for these people like a private event
yeah yeah yeah it was like this it was
called urban
ent or it was called urban ent and it
was in like san diego
on the beach at this rec center and it
was like a real hood
show and then it was like these couples
came out
and they spent like 200 dollars just to
be here
weird so just watch two hundred dollars
you bought
[ __ ] no no no no i mean i mean it was
like i was it doesn't sound like a great
setup it was like it was a ways behind
crack seagulls like
it was it was a great
right
[Laughter]
the white people are really nice
what did you do i went to santa barbara
the whole weekend with your girl yeah
now friday saturday no fault you weren't
on your phone cause we were texting the
group
and you're the only one that didn't get
back i woke up naked afraid like naked
and afraid on sunday because i didn't
know what was going on in the world and
she was so adamant about like turn your
phone off
no phone no news nothing nothing the
only thing we just stayed up did you
feel good
i felt good we communicated a lot that's
good that's pretty good
yeah i realized she talked a lot she's a
chatty oh
my god about what about everything about
stupid dumb
how to lose a guy in 10 days because i
haven't seen it yeah he's 15 years old
but yeah
again older than that it's a great movie
it was great yeah she talked like in
once she was i was like i've never seen
it
she's like oh my isaac's coming on she's
like oh my god i can't believe you
haven't seen it it's such a great
as the movie's coming out like yeah well
let me that's like jade during uh
documentaries when we watch him on the
road my brother jay he's my manager he's
on the road with
us he's he's friends with everybody but
we'll be watching documentary he talks
to the rich ramirez back dan you see
this [ __ ] anyways you know
when he was like i'm literally watching
yesterday all right so all right so for
valentine's
i went to uh i went to ralph's and i got
some um
and i got two balloons like valentine's
day balloons
and i i dropped them off it was windy as
[ __ ] by the way
yeah so i dropped them off on uh these
chicks and steps
and it was windy and i was like oh man
maybe i should put him in a better place
or whatever no i'm gonna leave him man
and i tried to do it so when she woke up
i was like oh [ __ ] oh my god
whatever [ __ ] drove off and um i said
hey uh
go open your door and it was like i
don't see nothing
i don't see nothing no the wind [ __ ]
blew
so now i look like i didn't do anything
for this person yeah you know and
she think i'm lying there's some chicken
you're dating her no yeah you dating her
you got a girl
oh no no no listen don't don't put
yourself in some situation yeah you
already
know don't worry don't worry nobody's
got that
you know that i i said i said this on on
the road and podcast but it's so it's so
um
it's so relevant it's like you know that
mitch hedberg joke is like oh i don't
got a girlfriend i didn't know a girl
who'd be really mad if i said that
[Laughter]
i flew back from san jose on sunday and
then stevie and i
ended up watching the zodiac killer uh
documentary staying and eating bootleg
pizza
oh did you pick it up yeah i picked it
up it was so good oh it's
so good so good so good see your little
cheat meal
wait what's that that bootleg might be
the best pizza i agree
that honey pepperoni oh [ __ ] i think
it's honey sausage
is it no it's like honey sauce honey
garlic
you know what i'm talking about though
it's a
bullet pizza that he discovered yeah
your boy
mike found it right um someone else mike
sent me a picture
like months ago i was like dog you need
to try michael turner michael
do you know white mike mike
if i saw him yeah maybe you saw white
mike you know he's going to put me on it
so you guys say boo like pizza watch the
richard ramirez doc is it good no not
richard ramirez uh
i uh it was on who oh the most dangerous
animal it's based off of that popular
book about the
zodiac killer there's a guy who thinks
that um his biological father was the
zodiac killer he made a whole book on it
and people read the book loved it
somebody decided to make a four-part
documentary on how he found
uh yeah on how he figured out his dad
was the serial killer and then
by the end it's like yeah
the zodiac killer was a serial killer in
northern california and they
never found out who was doing it he's
never been caught cool
ever he's brought in codes right yeah
anyway he would he would uh
send codes to the uh san francisco crime
people yeah that's nuts
oh then they just they try to try and
they just reset his code yeah
that yeah yeah part of it yeah they've
yeah some like someone don't notice [ __ ]
someone else i know what the zodiac
killer is yeah yeah super famous serial
killer they never caught him there's a
dope movie though
i think it's just robert downey jr and
uh jake gyllenhaal ooh he's good
he plays the killer no no they don't
have the killer it's a kind of a slow
burn trying to
it's super slow but if you like if you
know the story it's really really good
this came out 2007.
it's really really good is that that guy
on big sky like the ball here guy
uh i don't know that's uh he's just kind
of a guy yeah
yeah oh he's not like a main character
oh okay jim what'd you do for
valentine's day
i went uh cooked seafood my girlfriend
and then i just forgot i actually did
like electric bikes the first time
we both have electric bikes now oh wow
well you but you got like uh
like actual like almost like electric uh
it's not just a fat tire it's like a fat
tire yeah it's not like the e-bikes i'm
on
no mine's more for just like camping and
traveling it's foldable too
oh [ __ ] yeah yeah so your girl cruise
around on
the beach apply del rey all right so no
one really did [ __ ]
you kind of went to santa barbara santa
barbara get away your balloons
yeah you uh made chicken what did you do
yeah yeah yeah
we didn't i didn't do [ __ ] either
nothing no i went hiking with my kiddos
and that's about it i saw that dope post
with your uh dunks the best dunks of all
time oh the strange gloves yeah and the
roses in the back yeah
he was like the best dunks of all time
didn't you make cookies with them too
yeah i made cookies yeah you made
cookies yeah you could cook wow yeah
well
those are strange gloves people thought
it was cake
yeah i saw that i thought it was cake
too because there's
um a trend online where people will make
something look super realistic but then
you cut into it and it's a cake
that's insane that's hard actually no
those are great is that
cake no [ __ ] though dude those are
[ __ ] 13 people
yeah i should do a little like i can't
be making a cake at 37 years old
okay that would be funny somebody made a
cake out of that gorilla glue girl
oh yeah oh really yeah yeah did they
really
yeah it was hard as [ __ ] to cut though
because they made
yeah so because they made those like
realistic cakes i remember that they
made one of like a baby
you showed them like cutting into the
skull that's weird it's weird what the
[ __ ]
yeah people are waving is that that one
dude uh the guy goes bam
is that that guy that makes that cake
[ __ ] talking about flavor tomorrow
are you telling me emerald emerald he
makes it no oh no it's just like random
people
you make pasta pasta yeah emerald
emerald i thought he made the case he
goes bam
no he like seasoned [ __ ] and goes bam
original salty see that looks like a
cake though that one ain't that ain't
[ __ ]
i probably took forever but that [ __ ]
yeah that looks real oh
oh bruh
this [ __ ] is hard do you get the trend
now yeah
stop playing
oh [ __ ] he did that wait oh
i thought those tattoos look shitty
like undertaker yeah jamar you don't eat
crazy do you
um i can yeah every now and then i'll
[ __ ] some
damn those are dope yeah that looks
disgusting but it's
pretty well done i want to eat see i
want to eat that
i'm cool those are cool oh what's up
with another date night cat chin
you want another day night you're trying
to do it this week sure do you want
another like nine hour one or
yeah maybe maybe seven hours less than
the last one
oh yeah black history month oh yeah
i have it seemed like they stopped
celebrating black hit
history month like on the 10.
like they don't even let it work it's
more like a week and a half
they show the same thing as every black
history month too it's the same one yeah
the [ __ ] major super soakers
got to be more people yo so you studied
you went to clown school yeah yeah i
just be trying [ __ ] like that's what it
sounds like
yeah you never know man
you never know yeah is that where you
learned the back flips
uh nah like i was a hood kid i don't
think clowns be doing backflips yeah
they do
they do [ __ ] they have to be such
legit clowns cause they get all that
makeup and [ __ ]
and they got boots on and what clowns
are like hey kids
cool backplate yeah i would i would i
would i would do something
you're not a clown i know but if i was a
clown
but you were but you're a cheerleader
yeah and he was the hood
uh black panther oh yeah he was the hood
black what do you mean you were
bro [ __ ] the day black panther the day
black panther died [ __ ]
i showed up to my little uh nephew
birthday party dressed as the black
panther
bro he died do you have a video video of
it
yeah and it was like uh at the end of it
it was like that wasn't black
black panther dead
and that's him and that's not a black
panther he said he showed up on the roof
it's like all work all the way down down
yeah i go down to you
all he died probably a year ago
yeah yeah and they're they're not
bringing them back in the new black
panther
oh yeah right there the left oh [ __ ]
left
look at this dude
[Applause]
yo i was in england black panther doing
birthday parties in engle
black panther didn't even have a stick
just swinging it was a pinata
bro that's hilarious those kids are
crunk for it though yeah they're here
for it
[Applause]
here's the thing that's not even black
panther's mask
we got
dude
those kids those kids are like daddy
that ain't black panther
what a stick
this one yeah hold on well look this is
when he died and i was like i heard
y'all looking for a new black man
when they do that
little bubble like a new black fan you
[Laughter]
the kids are like why do you have a bow
stack and what do you have jock martens
his
[Music]
i was trying to do the black panther
fish and all that [ __ ]
yeah see you were not even doing this
but this is dude if you try renting a
super hero during covert times it's what
you
this is what you get i got this coveted
spider-man from my son's fourth birthday
party that [ __ ]
[ __ ] not fun oh [ __ ]
yeah i didn't charge him for that though
how did you get on the roof i mean i
i climbed up i climbed up on the side of
the house yeah
uh no no that was actually my auntie
house and my cousin put a uh
the way
he did it
[Applause]
you look like one of them birds from the
west
first of all that's a batman man
two black panthers would have been dead
you just pop up on the kids well then
you michael b jordan
who else was y'all gonna get huh i'm
gonna be with lori harvey but i'm here
with y'all
give me some of that cake okay
cakey look really [ __ ] my fruit snacks
oh bro bro it's so hot in here with
lauren harvey
i'm here with your little baby kids
oh my god that was the most proud
right
just imagine if kids just got finished
watching black panther you showed dude i
know right
if you do anything bad and the media
picks it up this would be the first
picture
jamar neighbors tomorrow also known as
black lance
pictured here they see this
[ __ ] stuff
i'm wearing
[Laughter]
we got ten yeah
i bet that was fun as [ __ ] though [ __ ]
you have a good time
yeah hell yeah he said i think
what's so funny because at that party
that's actually my little uh
nephew party at that party i didn't take
the mask off no nothing because [ __ ] if
i'm in character
i'm in character like i was really
sitting there [ __ ] eating wings and
[ __ ] with the mask
you ain't black panther y'all
[Applause]
no we have not seen canoe
oh shoot that what else have you been
doing in covington oh [ __ ] besides that
it's gonna weight yet besides that weird
black man you're so active bro
i'll be everywhere yeah everywhere um
what else have i been doing
just stand up when i can and um writing
have you been touring at all or did you
shut it down during coven
uh no like shows was uh shows started to
pick up
like uh right before they shut the uh
right before they shut it all down again
like drawing started to pick up you're
saying are you saying no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no
no no
no no
no no
no no
no no
no no
no no
no no
no no
no no
no no
no no no no no no no in town banana um
and then i guess like the touring that
i've only been doing was just been going
to austin
but like i do a gang of shows like in in
town like writing or
acting uh as far as stand-up
shows in town yeah as far as like
entertainment goes you're writing and
oh yeah yeah yeah right like i'm always
shopping some [ __ ] around that never
gets picked up
yeah and i'm like i always got like so i
always got like uh
like i always tell this thing all the
time and be like oh [ __ ] i got this
spot to pop
off me and then that [ __ ] never [ __ ]
happened like i'm gonna stop telling
[ __ ]
i don't tell anyone anything anymore
it's so far yeah and then two years
later remember having that
script you know yeah yeah well i
couldn't get picked up did it
yeah i'd be so optimistic and hyped
about like the [ __ ] that people promised
me and stuff i'd be like oh like i was
supposed to do [ __ ] with like a
adult swimming [ __ ] i was like oh [ __ ]
this [ __ ] is a pocket and then then cove
hit and then shut all my [ __ ] down and
i'm like damn
it's tough man yeah a lot of people
don't know you started off
your peer like with the girard
carmichael's the real ben yeah
who's part of your class jerrod we had
real josh out of myers
uh tony henscliffe uh
um a bunch of different [ __ ] yeah
beast a bunch of people like that yeah
tony tony in red full-time austin yeah
man yeah man they're [ __ ] out
there doing it yeah like
tony only does sold out shows you know
like that [ __ ] is [ __ ] lit
i'm just trying to i'm just trying to
bring some
bring some flavor out of it yeah you
know [ __ ] get that black panther
what's up with the roast battle stuff i
don't know i don't think [ __ ] no more no
oh you don't know that anymore
do you get weird when people ask you
that like old [ __ ] no no no no no i hate
when people bring up [ __ ]
like you was doing it for a minute yeah
i'm not crazy for asking
no no he was on tv with the rose battle
yeah and i'm not saying you i'm saying
it
when you're known for one thing oh god
someone brings it up no
no no i i love doing that [ __ ] it's just
like i won't do it no more yeah it is
yeah it's over i love doing the wave and
coming out and doing dumb look at
jeremiah
coming out here yeah yeah come out doing
crazy [ __ ] like that man i wish i could
do more
you had a dope ass battle though i
forgot who you are
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah y'all went hard
to paint bro [ __ ] we was
only like like like all the battles
happened like all the battles happened
that day
and then um they went with me and
yamaneka me
i'm a nika like we sang something like
that [ __ ] right yeah
i'm gonna bag on you like a bag like
like [ __ ] like a bag and
she did the [ __ ] saying and it was
like it was like watching like it was
like watching like the good time uh
parents argue
yeah yeah yeah i'm saying like [ __ ] and
we tore that [ __ ] place now because
it was a really good ass battle i was
like yeah
[ __ ] shut you up
ugly that went viral on twitter
yeah it went viral yeah yeah i remember
that [ __ ] man that [ __ ] was [ __ ] fun
we tore that place down man
i still personally believe i won that
battle i think so
who who decides who wins uh
oh they asked me one time but some i
couldn't do it i figured what was doing
yeah yeah so they got like three judges
and [ __ ] and um
they just picked like you know the best
of
so it's all kind of you know biased a
little bit
all right right you know what i'm saying
it's like no it can be
but i i personally feel like that battle
should have went
like one extra round but she she got
better but
i don't know i'm a sore loser yeah i'm
like man i still be thinking about that
[ __ ] like
man i ate that [ __ ]
it was a dope ass battle yeah but yeah
but that [ __ ] was [ __ ] fine no but i
don't do that i don't do that [ __ ] no
more though
all right tim what do you got
here we go okay so the daughter of the
lombardi trophy designer uh wants an
apology from tom brady for throwing
the trophy into the water i mean
wait what he didn't throw it into the
water she's just mad that he threw it
yeah so it's not like your dad came up
with some extremely extravagant like
trophy
football yeah with a handle she felt
like it was disrespectful that he was
throwing it similar to the way you
which he has several he has seven of
them yeah
he has several of those and threw it
like that caught it
yeah there's no there's no issue with it
she's just tripping
apology brady was faded though wrong
yeah yeah that'd
carry him out but i'm a big fan of him
now
it just upset me this trophy is
disgraced and district by being thrown
as a real football
she also has nothing going on in her
life yeah i have a big history of
this trophy being made by my father it's
such an honor and all the craftsmen that
made it
when my dad was there also tiffany's and
it takes a lot of hard work
so okay you get the if you get the
apology there's a football
on this yeah yeah that's what i'm saying
it's not like it's this crazy design
that nobody else could come up with
yeah pretty standard i don't give this
like ass you mean you took a foot kind
of weak as [ __ ]
yeah you mean you took a football and
just it was a great throw look
i don't see the problem yeah and he
caught it i'll see you proud and i think
could have killed somebody though
that's it yeah it's probably pretty
heavy look at him
he know what he did he turned up yeah
i mean he's like right with tom brady
yeah
and why is she looking yeah they
actually have nothing i mean yeah
nothing to do
i need an apology [ __ ] out of here an
apology yeah that's weird
the daughter's asking for it or not yeah
dad passed away yeah vince
martin but yeah a bunch of people
want uh apologies now and even after
they get they're never happy
i just brought you [ __ ] a
goddamn championship
i i think social like twitter wants an
apology the real world
doesn't give a [ __ ] about this have you
ever asked someone for an apology
never i don't know think about that
thinking about like
how think about that i don't like the
way what you said to me the other day
i didn't apologize yeah like my bad man
like thank you
yeah and then what if you have to ask me
to apologize
like you know i ain't going to mean it
like yeah yeah i got to go home from my
heart yeah no yeah
if i yeah exactly it's going to come
natural just apologize
that's weird what else you know and i'll
be fine i'll be fine
okay so there is a man in florida who
had a girlfriend
who he proposed to he gave her a ring
and everything
uh she then later went on to social
media and saw that there was a woman
wearing a very similar ring to what she
had
she was like huh that's weird she goes
through her things and notices that
her engagement ring that her boyfriend
gave her is gone she also realizes a few
other
pieces of jewelry are gone so about six
thousand dollars worth of her personal
jewelry
goes missing now she then contacts the
woman with a similar ring to hers and
says
hey um i've been missing a ring do you
happen to know so and so which is her
boyfriend
the woman says oh that's my fiance so he
stole the ring that he gave to his first
girlfriend to then propose to his second
girlfriend
but he also gave the second girlfriend
his first girlfriend's
jewelry as well they're both trying to
find him at this point
the second girlfriend is so bad about
the situation out he returned all the
jewelry was like sorry i don't want your
grandma's ring i'm sorry you're in the
situation with me
they're both trying to find him police
are after him because he stole jewelry
let's guess his ethnic ethnicity
did you see his name it's white what no
what to i'll figure out from his name
what's his name
uh it's gonna give it away oh yeah yeah
just guess just guess no i want to hear
his name
we already know what's his name no no
oh here here's another piece of uh
evidence
he goes by two names okay what city
uh this is in florida they say it's
orange city
oh or city oh it's definitely not black
i think he's black let me hear this
black for sure i'm gonna say black i'll
say two names i don't know why two names
i say i say names come on mexican yeah i
say white names
i say black there's not that i mean
there's one there's like dominicans in
florida
[ __ ] up because i know he has two
names that's when like a certain race
pops up in my head
but uh he went by joe brown for one girl
the second girl knows him as marcus
brown
yeah all right never mind sorry so he's
black yeah yes
okay so they were looking short
marcus brown i mean that's a boxer and a
support
so what ended up happening was they
couldn't find him for a few weeks and
they reached out to a family member that
he had over in north carolina the family
member says
oh this is my family member i don't know
where he is currently and they found him
in oregon he was actually arrested for a
hit-and-run
accident that involves injuries wait
there's more he's also in possession
of a fake id filing a fake police report
domestic assault and possession of
cocaine with intent to sell
italian job [ __ ] yeah i apologize i
thought
okay damn well all right case solved
what else you got uh okay so this uh we
were going to talk about it last week
but we never got oh britney's freed by
the way people didn't hit me up saying
uh brittany's free
oh really yeah i saw something with what
happened about her father
not being her father was like uh had
power over all her [ __ ]
because she said she's not mentally well
to handle
her own life pretty much how old is she
she is 49.
is that that's cause people send me that
as well it was on facebook
what the britney is free that was the
article on facebook
dreamland spheres warns me not to repeat
the mistakes in past in support of yeah
um yeah i heard i heard she's a it's a
little free
like your father doesn't have full
control anymore
i think sure that's what says her father
must share conservative [ __ ] which is
good
oh so he still has part of the
conservatorship but no yeah because she
wanted she wanted to give something to
the bank
yeah she was like that's cool if you
want to do this but i want my dad
running everything so i think it's
it's half and half now which is good so
he can't do anything without the bank
of what he's doing but he's holding on
all our money yeah yeah that's why she
hasn't performed she's like i ain't
performing if he's controlling
everything
so she shot every like declined hundreds
of millions of dollars she's like until
he doesn't have full control i'm not
performing because they would have went
to him
yeah so like a quick synopsis is
basically uh britney spears went through
some [ __ ] like back in 2007 people
thought she was unwell
they put her into a conservatorship
which basically means that someone else
is gonna look after her make sure that
nobody
takes advantage of her money make sure
that she's physically okay
takes care of her health they put her
father who wasn't in her life
in charge of that he's now in charge of
all her money and in charge of what she
can and can't do
and so it was supposed to only last a
few months but it lasted a few years and
now he's in charge of all of her money
he's also in charge of things like
whether she can have more kids or not
and she currently can't see her kids
because her
the father of her children actually
filed a restraining order against her
father
because the father i guess hit one of
the kids and so it's just a [ __ ] up
situation where she legally can't
live her own life and make her own
decisions
and they try to make a situation into a
business that way
so i was like [ __ ]
i don't know why i just think it's all
funny
it's it's all such a [ __ ] show yeah it's
a [ __ ] show but you see the way the
media treated brittany it's so funny
2007 right around town
yeah yeah uh but a lot of people were
giving justin timberlake [ __ ] for
they want him to apologize they wanted
to apologize they wanted an apology from
from what though what do you do because
he wrote crimea river and
in the documentary that came out
recently about britney spears they said
that it's
a big reason why the media then
portrayed her as like a [ __ ] and
started like because he's saying that
she cheated on him that's why he wrote
cried me a river they're saying the
media went after
yeah yeah they showed up you wrote the
denim on
them at the mtv music awards that [ __ ]
also it was like disney kids or
something yeah yeah yeah
yes him christina aguilera they're all
together oh
but yeah he went on instagram and wrote
an apology from his like notepad
and he apologized to britney as well as
janet jackson for uh
the super bowl boob thing you just
apologize for everything
yeah he's saying that he feels bad he
didn't take it upon himself
to he was a kid for that man i mean it's
in the past
he's a kid
i'll tell you what slaps is american
idol started last night right now
who's that who's judging on there right
now it's katy perry right katy perry
luke bryan and uh lionel richie
i like lion orange but it but where's
simon he's not all been there
you know he hasn't been on there like 10
years
really he doesn't do x factor anymore he
does x factor now because i think he
owns a part of like that
yeah but but the american idol i don't
like it when it's like top 10 when it
gets all serious and
they have themes and [ __ ] i like it now
we hear all their stories and people
[ __ ] up you heard about you watch the
girl with her baby the mexican girl with
her baby
and she sung her ass off
it was i watched last night that was the
first episode can you see it no
you're making that [ __ ] what season they
on it's a clip i don't know
they're bawling though but that last
night man they just they just pull out
your heartstrings man like last night
this uh big girl wrote a song because
her mom left her like a year ago just
dipped out on the family so she's
writing a song to her mom
everybody crying in that [ __ ]
they passed her now she's a good singer
probably not
they passed the story oh yeah but then
some
some of those girls can sing man some
girl with tourette's went off what
jennifer hudson passed she came through
that uh american idol she finished i
think tenth
time yeah because it's about the story
once it gets yeah yeah
i think the key to success on that show
is like don't win
get like second or third place you don't
want to win
yeah well kelly clarkson won those are
the only two that really popped off
afterwards yeah
ruben stuttered he didn't win yeah
the greatest thing of all time
top five
like some of the [ __ ] that she's done
like compared to like a reality it's
like to me
yeah so here we go and she also had a
biopic like really shortly
yeah yep yep so when we talk about like
comparing it like to
carrie underwood like carrie underwood
or kelly clarkson they're
[ __ ] crushing their major yeah big
time but fantasia got 4.4 million
followers oh i thought that was her
right there go down
right there you mean the middle and the
black [ __ ]
you know damn well she's
good trying to stay super positive
yeah certain american idols even when
they win it they just don't connect yeah
it's just like reuben never played clay
aiken i was just
he only does christmas [ __ ] really yeah
that's basically it
one of them girls oh yeah the country
singers kill it the country singers kill
it oh jordan sparks
adam lambert adam uh yeah he's killing
it
is he on the uh the voice he sings for
uh queen
yeah oh i mean he's seeing someone's
other someone else's son yeah
virgin sparks yeah again compared to
like kelly clarkson and carrie underwood
carrie underwood is the best of all this
place
he ran for i think mayor of like south
carolina but it's gonna be tough to win
there and be gay let's just call it is
he gay
oh yeah well you can play you can you
think you know grown man wears all that
makeup just for the [ __ ] of it didn't he
he came out alone he's on tv
no that's a podcast bro you ever seen me
with makeup on this
he's wait he been gay man google if he's
gay he been gay
people we're trying to tell you uh ran
for office he was running at
like with his party i thought that was
just like the first
[Laughter]
13 years ago but he's the runner-up
before
he didn't fall he lost a reuben yeah he
lost reuben stuttered
lakeland to rioville he's gay everyone's
like yeah no [ __ ]
the picture is a vampire look at that
picture
yeah he gay gay oh [ __ ] yep my bad
yeah i love american idol what else you
got this is in iraq
so i guess there's these syrian brown
bears that uh the people there
can actually bring into their home and
try to take care of right so they're
it's not iraq that they're showing
there's no snow in iraq like that is
there
yeah really so it says for once iraq
looked fun
right i like the on the far left
laughing and running
look at the guy with the shades on like
rick flocks
oh [ __ ] he does he does like rick fox
this guy so so they had a like a
thing with bears and just released so
they would get you know they'll get it
from people they're trying to own these
bears and they'll
rehabilitate them and they were trying
to release it into this area here
so when they released it the bears came
back and tried to like
charge them yeah eat them i mean i mean
they're just freaking out right you see
pictures here
so they had them on a cliff a little
cliff here
they're gonna open the gate and then the
bears will come out
this is what you get man people a little
too comfortable with [ __ ] beers like
in russia they want to wrestle them and
[ __ ] here we know better
it only happens overseas man there's a
little bit of footage oh
oh [ __ ] well he thinks everybody's
playing yeah
he doesn't know what's going on yeah
that should look fun right now
it didn't seem like anyone was hurt
though look at the bears were like
fighting nurses i mean like running with
the bulls and [ __ ] oh
the bears kind of thought everyone was
playing like yeah let's [ __ ] diss
this thing
there you go i guess they get snow
northern northern iraq
um so police officers in bed in beverly
hills are playing
beatles song and also like uh sublime
songs when people are recording them
like activists when they want to record
them you can't upload to instagram
because as soon as you do it it's a
copyright infringement because they try
to do it live
and you catch the officers doing
something shady you know so the officers
start playing needles yeah they'll play
the song the beatles it'll get like
the cop and the copyright thing will you
know what a weird thing to do
wait these cops are overthinking it wait
wait i'm about to shoot this dude
hold on let me get my playlist out doug
do it
the cop even said like i don't want to
be caught you know saying something and
then you take it out of context and
upload it and then my life is you know
cause that's what they're doing they're
editing a lot of this to make it seem
like they're all bad people
some of them police brutality uh videos
be actually sketches
[Laughter]
but you can do that like when i was on
the ultimate fighter if we were going to
talk about something we didn't want on
the
show well someone was talking the other
person next
to just name off like uh big companies
like pepsi coke mountain bikes
like cheetos flame hot cheap and just
keep naming brands and they couldn't use
those bits
wow so we'd be talking about something
serious i'm like hey dude go and they
just start naming [ __ ] off
dallas cowboys just start naming off
main brand [ __ ] and they can't use any
of the footage wow
these cops figured that out 30 years
later
i saw this on tim kennedy's instagram
this mother the attack
oh yeah i saw that so i guess this guy
was a peeping tom looking through that
her daughter's window 15 year old
daughter
and he tried to run away from the cops
and then she grabbed him this is texas
yeah
and they you know have a chance to get
caught up that's phyllis pena in the red
shirt
the daughter's like no no no
i heard that guy the suspect dapped her
up after was a good tackle
really yeah it was like type movement
that's the suspect too
you interesting right he looks like he
had it tackled by a mom
i would have stepped on them
like derrick henry in that [ __ ]
yeah yeah okay
all right chappelle you got some current
events too right [ __ ] yeah i do what's
up
you got current events oh yeah dude uh
this is gonna be a backflip
riffraff riffraff is calling out six
nine mm-hmm
it's a box for a million dollars for uh
no not a million a meal
for real yeah i thought it was a hundred
thousand so the uh okay look at him
i encountered [ __ ] fight jamar no says
hello six and i see that you are
you like to attempt to start fights with
real artists that have police records to
where if they were to kick your ass
like meek mill um go jail [ __ ] their
money up so i
dale dan tony which no felony record
would like to turn the tables and play
your game with you
as well as up the stakes i challenge you
nine in boxing oh [ __ ]
for one million in cash we both put a
million in a class case
at a pay-per-view event and the winner
takes all i will be training starting
today i would suggest you do as well i
will give you three months of training
as well
see you in the ring you little mosquito
six niner power whip his ass look at
this [ __ ] he's forming i think so
six you ever seen six nine's body he has
the worst body in rap
oh you saw him this weekend punk uh
trying to get mixed
so he showed up with his like they're at
a strip club
now he waited outside meek mill hotel
and mcmillan he was walking out 69 went
crazy like
you [ __ ] you got security with you and
all right for real yeah he went crazy
six nine wasn't alone no he had his body
his goons were with him too
no he have goals yeah security his body
goes that's what i'm saying so it's not
like he's rolling up their
solo to fight why did he do it just for
random well me mcmill talk so much [ __ ]
about him oh
wait everybody talks [ __ ] about him yeah
you're gonna meet me
that's the fact you [ __ ] that's the
fact
it was security this is security
and you win police hey this looks
exactly you should have gave someone
else the cell phone
i know it was another angle as well
i feel like six nine would get his ass
with by meek mills oh absolutely yeah
i think he just did this i don't see
either of them fight here's the other
thing
anybody doing well in business or
stand-up or
podcast or tv or movies they ain't doing
these celebrity boxing matches
it's only people that have nothing else
to do name
a name somebody who's doing celebrity
boxing who's crushing the game
name one jose canseco life is in
shambles who else
jake lamar odom well yeah the paul
brothers not celebrity they're not doing
celebrity boxing they're doing real bad
they're doing real boxing i'm talking
about lamar odom
[ __ ] the car nick carter right right
like their lives are in shame
jose conseco it's like ain't nobody
who's doing shits doing these celebrity
boxing matches
they're doing it for a quick payday
there's nothing else they have no other
skills
that's why they're doing it and people
will watch it
uh yes and no i lamar owed about the
fight who are you yeah eric carter
remember the dude who came oh
yes
yeah that's fair that's fair yeah the
non-talented bieber
yeah i saw him uh i saw him getting
ready for a show in new york maybe like
six years ago we just ran into like his
rehearsal by accident
and he was rehearsing for a show and
yeah i remember that
wow
oh where's aaron carter at he's fighting
lamar odom
wait eric wait who nick was their older
brother that was in uh
boys oh oh i saw aaron carter yeah yeah
getting ready the smaller one didn't he
come out as like pansexual or something
i think he came out as bisexual what's a
pansex what's a pansexual you you're
you're attracted to whatever it's more
so about the personality i believe
pansexual sounds gay
[Laughter]
uh chappelle again yeah what's this um
so this dude is rocking
the [ __ ] vans and look how fit he is
oh that's it yeah that's why i showed it
there's some random shredded black guy
in
let me tell you something i got my
[ __ ] vans on right now those weren't
those exact ones those and i'm not
taking these hoes off
until i lose 15 pounds is that your
mission statement so you're wearing them
for
those shoes quite some time 50 miles be
i mean that's no pun you know how much
you trying to lose you know that's over
30. you know
exactly that's a boy who played for the
ravens is that look at this
you know the wide receiver that's an
offset that's not that's not you're
talking about
antoine bouldin he was in nfl click on
his profile
chin he's jacked yeah what what
we're tired what city super ball champ
yeah that's what i'm saying
who did he play for i think he played
for the ravens
oh [ __ ] look at this girl far left
spent about that down the water some saw
some whales [ __ ] was cool as [ __ ]
yeah she's getting it yeah he's getting
it that's his girl
i don't know that's one of them i think
well he's killing it
damn they fit let's go chapelle i i take
my vans off
so i look like him well then you ain't
taking them
well it looks like you wearing vans for
quite some time [ __ ] you
how much does he weigh 194. i'm sorry
not the brock
the broncos he's a safety i'm not i'm
not trying to get
194. chicago as well he's a baller
yeah he's from california wait he's
510 yep i'm five eleven hundred ninety
four pounds that's only twenty more hit
professional athletes me at 194 would it
look weird
you'd look like him i would probably not
but either way
you'd be healthier this whole for real
so you're not you're you're gonna wear
those vent come on though you don't wear
those
goddamn that food looks good
you're gonna wear those vans until you
lose 15. uh no
that's actually a bit much uh five
all right why are you laughing five
that's cool i mean you could lose five
and water weight i mean tomorrow
why the white guy okay ten ten seconds
do ten yeah
ten what'd you say
he said we asked why that white guy
looks so serious he goes he looks
pansexual
he really does that he looks like yeah
that's all right that's his girl on the
ground go up chad let me see this one
yeah oof doggy
good for him that's what you get when
you're in shape
yep okay so you think 10 pounds is good
then 10 pounds for the vans otherwise
you may be wearing vans for the next
[ __ ] six
months you know what i'm saying and it's
also it's not like you're
you're disciplining yourself you love
vans so
these man like if i if i don't lose 10
pounds i'm gonna keep these vans on when
i met you that's all you wore
hey little beat little b said he wasn't
changing his vans until he made a
million who the [ __ ] a little b
that's right rapper bass god basically
uh thank you [ __ ]
does he like vans or something like my
thing would be like i'm not wearing
craw like i'm only gonna wear these
crocs do i lose 20 pounds so you say i
hate something like that
you need something you love vans so it's
not going to motivate me
wearing bright colors i do hate wearing
bright colors so you're wearing bright
colors till
you lose tempo yellow
yeah makes sense until you look until
you make it to one
ten pounds oh all right well you think i
should he said 10
is smart i said 15 at first it took him
two weeks to lose 12 pounds
yeah so how long would it take you to
lose 10 pounds probably not that long
okay well yeah bright clouds that time
you could do it if you got straight
you're doing a month yeah
you wearing some bright ass colors for a
month hell yeah
thank you yeah man but sometimes i don't
know how they feel
yeah yeah yeah yeah you can do it
i lose two pounds she's like hey she
looked the same dog
since i met you since i met you
for sure
you can do it for sure but yeah if
you're gonna discipline yourself not the
you love fans fans are your fate and
vans are great to work out in
i know that's why that's what motivated
me that's hard for you to lose 10 pounds
is it no you just need you need a reason
to do it right
because i don't like the way i feel so
that should be a good reason
yeah not your vans you're a vans guy
dude
i don't like the way y'all going you can
take a bath and uh and epsom salt
for real yeah yeah and then fighters
yeah
you lose weight that way yeah but she
only come back
like that's not real weight loss we're
gonna have a scale if we keep forgetting
we're gonna bring the scale yeah bring
the scale i need the nail
because i'm too i think i'm 255. but he
doesn't i think he's i think he's around
i'm breaking on wednesday i think he's
two six two six there's no way what
happens when you get to uh what happens
when you
when you get then i said then that's my
that's my lifestyle
once you lose ten yeah i'm making it a
lot more than ten though
i know yeah yeah yeah but ten i i think
i could do like start yeah
what two weeks yeah ten pounds two weeks
i say a month you gotta be
you think a month for ten pounds this
[ __ ] from just eating and working out
now he's not jumping no soccer bro and i
go skateboarding i've been starting
skating
dave borton how many how many big ass
skateboarders do you know no but he
talked about two weeks
how about
y'all talking [ __ ] all right i ain't
talking no more i don't wanna do it i
know i'm gonna i don't know
i'm gonna get [ __ ] up
i'm gonna sit in my car
yeah we have all
i'm not sure we can play this song but
i'll just show you this clip so there's
a country singer who wrote a song for
his daughter
and his daughter knew that he was
writing for it but he never finished it
so this is him playing it for her as he
as she's listening for the first time
that it's finished
so she doesn't know yet
[Music]
gonna make me cry
what are those suggestions
that's like a big dick the [ __ ] tick
tock
like if you like this you're gonna love
wow that's pretty cool though in the
moment but that's cool
will dempsey that's cool to will
yeah is he is he an actual artist he's
an artist but i don't think he's that
big but this thing went viral
oh probably gonna blake his voice is
good really good yeah yeah
hell yeah and that's pretty much it for
current events that's cool man
cool jamar what
that's the show man you did it oh that's
it that's it this ain't broken i don't
know right
yeah you don't go for four or five
people got [ __ ] to do man
i was tired i was like damn
[Laughter]
theo said he did rogan and he called me
he was damn man
that's the longest i've ever talked to
another human being i haven't talked to
my mom for three hours
and when you think about it like damn
you right man yeah
it's a long time well it's been a long
time to talk i'm in tampa florida
february 26
27th that's next friday and saturday
kids the
tampa improv out there and then
cleveland ohio we just added
two new dates cleveland ohio march 11th
through the 13th at uh hilarity's shout
out to my boy nick at cleveland ohio
uh hilarity's march 11th 13th cleveland
spokane washington this is a rescheduled
date so the shows are basically sold out
they're adding a date on that thursday
though
they're on the show march 18th work on
my birthday hell yeah
march 18th through the 20th spokane
washington and then florida end of the
month
ticket to f-a-t-k-z.com
and also thick boys doing a giveaway uh
it's a 101 custom helmet it's signed by
me thick boy
uh helmet i love it the way you can win
is just subscribe to the thick boy
uh email helmet giveaway subscribe
you get you can uh you subscribe to
the pick a winner if you subscribe to
the email and if you
you can double your chances to win if
you subscribe and buy merch from
thickboy.com
they're going to decide to win on
february 28th so get after it
thickboy.com for all that chappelle
where are you at doug i'm in kansas city
at uh february 25th through the 27th at
the comedy club of kansas city
i will not be eating barbecue uh i've
decided to
you know hopefully find a trainer out
there that i can work out with the whole
weekend
because uh i'm really trying to lose
this 10 pounds and then also i'll be in
austin texas
uh march 5th and 6th uh at the vulcan
gas company
two only two shows so one friday one
saturday
let's sell that out austin and then uh
got new merch yeah merch drop
new love i love this tie it looks cool
it looks great i still gotta get rented
i want to listen to no i still
haven't i gotta pick it up i gotta pick
it up from the ups so
yeah chappelleacy.com for all that stuff
blah blah blah jamar
anything doug yeah i gotta
there you go my [ __ ] all right man uh
february 20th i'm at big sports bar in
houston
um got that and then i'm going to be in
austin
march 2nd 5th 9th 16th
23rd march 30 of doing the apartment
show and i got my uh
my podcast in mars neighborhood and um
that's it hell yeah yeah well i'm glad
you finally got on here man we love you
dude
i love you guys energy man yeah this is
so [ __ ] goofy
i'm glad you could get silly wooden all
right
all right we're out
with black socks like that yeah what do
you want to wear
who are you yeah i'm just a comic
book i'll never get rid of these i'm
just like i forgot about that
oh malik b rolly boy you know what i
mean getting reaching for a fetch
coming from a duplex shout out to the
homies that's suplex look at this
valley rolly boy it's got hulks
autumn is hard yeah super they do
different shoes yeah suplex game
same shoe they just make them look
different i'll say i'm sorry yeah same
shoe just two different uh shoes
all right get the marilyn manson's up
there
first and foremost jamar malachi
neighbors
[ __ ] these shoes make me taller
three different colors black punk rock
[ __ ]
[ __ ] you barely matching my ass
he can suck my dick with his ribs out
check out your other ribs
island